they've been ordering online all weekend
it's because of the pandemic of course
we've seen the increase in online
shopping that means more packages
will be delivered on your doorstep over
the coming weeks
bianca holman is live to share how to
protect your holiday gifts
from thieves good morning bianca porch
pirates
boy they're already out and doing their
work aren't they
yeah you know we talk about this every
single year how the grinch stole
christmas may be your favorite holiday
movie but for some
it becomes a reality that's because
thieves are looking to steal your
packages
right from your doorstep but there are a
few things that you can do to of course
protect your packages again that you
spent your hard-earned money on
to deliver to loved ones and uh some of
those include
of course having your cameras ready and
up working having a security system
but there are some criminals that
actually follow the trucks
quietly waiting nearby for the chance to
steal your packages so of course you
have the option to let your delivery
driver know where to leave your package
you can actually let them know hey put
it over the fence
or put it behind a large plant on your
porch and of course a major step in
protecting your packages having that
doorbell camera and some type of
security system
and you can of course register that
camera with metro
what people need to do is target harden
their own
residence or their own place of business
and you know advise your neighbor if
you're not going to be around or you
expect to receive a package or if you
have a security guard
through an hoa advise them and help help
you
have their video cameras working that's
a definite assist for the police
department do an investigation
and it's important for people to be
aware of their surroundings so
don't make it easy for the crooks
the sheriff also mentions don't post
your information
online or on social media saying you'll
be out of town
don't make it obvious or put any factors
out there that you're not going to be at
home
so again you heard him say let your hoa
security guard know let a neighbor know
and of course have those
cameras at your home working or even a
sign
that's saying that you have a security
system that can deter thieves as well
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now
bianca thank you very much coming up
next year on good